[Music]
g'day i'm dean marchiore i'm a
statistician from sydney australia
and i'm interested in reproducible
analysis and workflow choices in r
but in my day-to-day practice in
industry as a commercial data scientist
is my work actually reproducible to
answer this i conducted a
reproducibility retrospective
or repro retro i went back through the
last year of my commercial data science
projects and rated each project across a
number of dimensions that are valued in
my practice
you can pick aspects that suit your work
but the dimensions i picked
cover if an analysis were replicable
modular
auditable automated and collaborative
so what were the results out of 55
projects i scored an average of 3.8 out
of 5.
this is good but not great so if i care
so much about this why wasn't my work
rated higher here are the lessons i took
from my repro retro
controversial opinion number one not
everything needs to be reproducible
while all projects benefited from some
aspect of reproducibility
the most important consideration for me
was how do you tell
what needs to be reproducible
enter my fiji test so if you have a task
that's sufficiently important you may
want to consider the fiji test
aussies like fiji because it's only a
few hours away
but if you're lying on a beach in
holidays in fiji just spare a thought
for your colleagues back in the office
if they need to rerun some of your
analysis will they be able to find it
understand your work run it without too
much fuss
and make reasonable enhancements or
small changes
the last thing you want while you're
sipping your pina colada is to be
disturbed by a weird phone call about
some model that you trained
when i looked at the type of analytics
task i completed not everything needed
to pass the fiji test
a lot of work in industry is ad hoc and
quite simple
you know commercial or a high pressure
environment i think it's perfectly
reasonable to have
different standards on workflow choices
depending on the type of work and the
return on investment that you need
so long as a reasonable standard is
maintained
and as long as your team is consistent
with these choices
however this may mean getting better at
anticipating the full scope of the
project
before rushing into solving a problem
which can be a challenge
in addition it gives you the freedom to
pick a more lightweight and flexible
workflow choice if desired
my next lesson was picking the right
tools for the job you know i've been
searching for the biggest and best
workflow choice
but i found it paid to have options when
i examined my tooling and workflow
options
the results of my repro retro varied
using
a basic directory structure template to
organize my projects was
okay or round but quickly got cumbersome
notebooks like our markdown were nicely
replicable but
tended to be a bit of a dumping ground
for code drake
a more formal workflow system carried a
bit more overhead and more admin to get
used to
but overall it enforced much better
standards particularly around writing
functional and modular code while any
system can be made arbitrarily
sophisticated and do a good
job i found it more effective to have a
few different workflow choices available
rather than try a one-size-fits-all
approach all workflow choices are
naturally optimized for certain
applications
and i found it better to only take on
additional complexity
when the job really needed it next i
found in my work i had a tendency to
mistake
replication for reproduction and the
same goes for automation
getting your code to re-run is only part
of the solution so
consider the factors that matter in your
practice and be deliberate about what
you optimize for
and use that to guide your workflow
choice and how do you do that
well do a repro retro the process
wasn't and isn't intended to be
scientific or unbiased
the true value of a repro retro is in
the self-reflection
and improvement so go and dig through
your old code and think about how you
might do things better
if you want to learn more you can reach
out to me or visit my analysis flow
github repo i'd also like to acknowledge
and thank my collaborator miles mcbain
for many interesting discussions in this
space
thank you and good luck
you